on the streets of xinjiang there is
still attention and signs of what this
place has been through
heavy police regular stops
a sense they're always watching
it is now Infamous for its brutal
oppression of the Muslim uygha minority
and there are questions as to how far
that policy is ongoing
it is the camps that characterize the
Crackdown places like this
experts and survivors say it once held
uyghurs arrested on mass and subject to
so-called re-education but we found it
Dusty deserted
it's really an incredible eeriness to
this place and it just is completely
abandoned
signs of what used to be are everywhere
though
[Applause]
around the front one building cordoned
off from the rest appeared to be acting
as temporary housing
and some of the buildings over there are
they empty
I don't know this man says there were
people here when I first arrived
that ominous
looking Kemp was built where we had
beautiful dreams as a children it's
unbearable it's Unthinkable this place
is haunting for mechan he knows his
brother Emma Tian was held here it might
be closed but his brother is not free
after two years here without charge a
police officer told him what happened
next according to the police officer he
said that my brother
had a sensitive book which was banned by
the government uh impromptu kind of
court was held court hearing was held in
the camp and he was sentenced to 14
years
China says everyone held for
re-education has now graduated
over 90 percent of the re-education
camps we visited were visibly no longer
being used for this purpose most now
appear to be schools the reality may be
far more complex
in fact while arrests spiked in 2017 at
the height of the Crackdown they remain
higher than they were before it started
prosecutions jumped up too and there was
a huge increase in average sentences
meaning most of those people will still
be locked up
if not in the camps then where
what we're now doing is taking a trip
further outside the city center because
what we've heard is that the camps that
are further out are more likely to be
still used for that purpose and that's
also where some of the larger prisons
are that we think in some cases might
have been expanded some it seems they
did not want us to see
we found all the roads to one large
cluster of facilities were blocked
those we did reach were fearsome eight
in total all clearly operational and
satellite shows some have recently
expanded in 2018 towards the end of the
Crackdown this site hadn't even been
started watchtowers added just recently
and here too a prison right next to a
re-education camp extended while the
camp part had its walls and watchtowers
removed
the initial wave of arrests might have
passed but the fear they've wrought has
not this woman is one of the very rare
few to have escaped within the last two
years even from a place of safety she is
visibly terrified it's all lies most
people are still inside although it
looks as if everything's normal people
who were deemed a bit problematic had
taken always and no one knows where
they've been taken to they don't say
anything about what happened to them
when they were inside but it's obvious
that they've experienced extreme horror
in response to our story China's foreign
Ministry said allegations of the camps
are sheer lies and that vocational
schools helped people break away from
terrorist and extremist ideas everyone
has now graduated
the message is that everything is normal
here now the Crackdown may be less
visible for many it still feels very
real Helena Smith Sky News in xinjiang